this is how important workers are these
days and how much how much um
pull
how much clout workers have right now
have you heard about what's going on in
portugal
no check this story out so workers are
so important that in portugal they're
making laws to basically give you a
better work-life balance they're
basically saying when you're not working
we ain't gonna bother you portugal has
now officially made it illegal
for your employer your boss to even
contact you outside of working hours
after five o'clock lose my [ __ ]
number jeffy
this is crazy cnbc story so basically
they they highlight portugal they say
portugal has passed new labor laws
basically this applies to any company
with 10 or more employees so if you're a
two-man three-man operation this doesn't
apply to you or nor does it apply to you
if you're not in portugal but in
portugal here's what they've basically
um laid out in their new labor laws
they've banned bosses from contacting
employees outside of working hours we
discussed that they said that workers
should have the right to at least 11
consecutive hours of a nice night's rest
during which they should not be
interrupted and less for major
emergencies okay they've also said that
the employers contribute to the staff's
work from home expenses they're
basically saying yeah that internet that
i use and the electricity that i use
yeah you're paying for that now el jefe
okay what else that bosses are expected
to meet with the members of their staff
face to face every two months not a big
deal but basically if the employers
don't abide by this if they're basically
calling their employees all all hours of
the night they're not respecting them
you know they're they're 11 hours of a
peaceful night's rest if they're not
paying part of their utility bill that
goes to internet electricity yada yada
that they could be fined geez watch out
i hope uh tais isn't watching this our
event coordinator she's in portugal
right now she just might say that where
she is okay just might stay
so here's my question here we've talked
about four-day work weeks in iceland we
talked about in um
portugal basically saying not contacting
me there you see what's going on here in
japan people being burnt out they're
basically saying
you know this is the the new wave of
work
is is any of this here's my question to
you young dave yeah is any of this going
to happen in america today is any of
this going to happen in america today
some of it not all of it so
the drug testing i can see it happening
right yeah as marijuana becomes more
uh recreationally legal yeah totally
that stuff like that but new york just
opened up safe places to go do heroin oh
did they yeah um so it's like in new
york i know that they have that in san
francisco no in new york liberal
bastions of free drugs and love okay um
the contact hours they might make it
illegal but it's still gonna happen
um
the four-day work week i don't see that
happening in the states because here's
the thing
and if it does
it's just gonna keep uh
50 years there'll be a dave casper
three-day work week dave yeah and we'll
talk about the three-day work week
because
yeah right now four-day work week sounds
awesome but it's it's not a party if it
happens every night right so it's like
at some point it's just like oh man
[ __ ] in four days bro i work all four
days this week isn't that crazy you're
saying it's a slippery slope yeah then
it's gonna say it starts with five next
thing you know it's four a handful of
years down the road it's three a while
now it's like oh my god i gotta go to
work today one day a week this is so
[ __ ] annoying yeah i'm gonna have to
[ __ ] drive to the office today bro
what the [ __ ] yeah everyone's gonna work
from home it's so it's like keep it at
five yeah it sucks
but it doesn't it's just it used to be
seven no it's five you know what i think
you know what i think you know what i
think and i think implement yeah four
day work week four day work week fridays
work from home
meet me in the middle here hey fridays
we do a zoom call everybody's on at 9am
whatever it is
there's a noon check-in make sure you're
doing something whatever if you get your
[ __ ] done go enjoy the rest of your
friday if you still got stuff to catch
up on gotta work extra on a friday i'm
just i'm just thinking of like that's
ways to compromise here yeah like perks
from home because five days a week
that's eighty percent of your life your
work and your work and you're working
now here's the deal
if you love what you do yeah
dude you work seven days a week you
don't care you're doing it like maybe
you take sunday off take us here at
valley team and we're here until 11
o'clock at night we love working here i
mean obviously people got different
schedules no absolutely some people you
know they get paid their salary they get
paid their hourly and they just
they're not they're not as pat calls it
part of the 459 club 459 packing up yeah
that's not a good sign wherever you are
whether it's three days a week four days
a week five whatever it is if you're
part of the 459 club you're just dying
to get the [ __ ] out of the office find
another job bro yeah you know i guess it
you know it's so easy these days some
people end up leaving like those people
end up finding something else that's
true but us i mean people some people
stay here because they
enjoy enjoy it they don't mind yeah yeah
i need to catch up on something or
they'll come in early i came in the
other day 6 a.m paul was here people
were here already working okay
shout out to the valuetainment squad
doing their thing if you enjoyed that
short clip from the sauce cast click
here to watch another click here to
watch the full episode or just stay
broken